my name is penny Jarrah I'm a business
developer youth mentor and blogger and I
have ADHD which is attention deficit
hyperactive disorder ADHD is a mental
disorder which causes behavioral issues
a lot of people think that people have
ADHD can't pay attention but the thing
is is we can just pay too much attention
so paying attention to the wrong things
or a lot of things at once sometimes I
feel like I've got eight brains and each
one has like 40 tabs open I could be
talking to someone and then another tab
opens and I just start thinking about
something else and I give it my full
attention like I feel like I have to
give it my full attention for like three
seconds people with ADHD have a lot of
energy so there's a lot of fidgety and
we can't keep still we usually have
struggles following instructions we get
distracted a lot so it means that we
don't finish things and sometimes don't
even start things there are loads of
good things about ADHD too so an ADHD
brain is usually creative there are
loads of artists comedians fingers yeah
there's loads of creatives we've got
great imaginations which lead to a good
sense of humor so we're funny and I
think that's a lot to do with just doing
funny things all the time like I
sometimes find my remote in the fridge
managing ADHD includes managing your
environment so you're not always gonna
have control over where you are for
instance I if I'm in a white room like
just completely bland I find that I
start getting kind of like breathless
and panicky and like looking around and
just just can't focus on anything but if
I'm somewhere which is colorful and
vibrant I feel calm and yeah I think
that's why my house is quite colorful I
didn't realize it before but when I got
diagnosed I looked around me and I was
like okay managing and holding down a
normal 9 to 5 job is mad I've even
walked out of meetings I've been a
meeting rooms and yeah just have the
urge to just walk out I didn't even
notice until I was halfway down the
corridor that
what is in a meetin it's just the
Braille understimulated it just searches
for stimulation in any way and if that
has to be outside of that room then ya
me get when I'm selling to customers on
the phone
I make affirmation cards handmade with
sharpies and pencils and they have
positive words on things that I can look
at and remember when I'm having anxious
thoughts or just not feeling good even
if I'm not trying to focus on something
in particular like a phone call I need
to be changing what I'm doing so that I
can give enough energy to all my tasks
so if I had a to-do list with like 10
things on it for the day where a
neurotypical person might do each one at
a time maybe maybe even put them in
order of priority I can't always figure
out which one I should prioritize and
that's interesting actually because
people of ADHD have an interest-based
nervous system so yeah we find
prioritizing hard if I time box myself
and give 15 minutes to each thing and
keep coming back then I'm stimulated
enough to complete all of them and yeah
at a high level
I was only diagnosed with ADHD last year
when I was 30 so at first it was like
such a negative to me after doing a lot
of research I stopped I stopped feeling
negative about ADHD because I learned
about all the good things the best thing
about having ADHD I think is hyper focus
and what that means is that we can
actually Zone into that thing for
several hours and it not feel like
several hours and we go in so hard
masterpieces come out of it and that's
why yeah a lot of creatives I think they
master what they do if they've got ADHD
because when hyper focus kicks in yeah
nothing will distract you
not even hunger or sleep
ADHD is manageable so it doesn't have to
remain negative and it doesn't have to
like to find you in a negative way the
symptoms of ADHD are with me and they
always will be but they don't have to
define me in a negative way if I learn
how to manage my ADHD then I learn how
to manage my life and I can be just as
productive and successful as I want just
not every single day
you